This week, we will use
the concept of momentum
to analyze some more
advanced situations.
Namely, systems in which there
is a continuous flow of mass
rather than just the
motion of discrete objects.
The classic example
of this is the thrust
due to exhaust from
a rocket engine.
Once again, we will appeal
to a differential analysis
technique.
Breaking the flow down into a
large number of small elements,
analyzing one of the elements in
detail, and then generalizing.
This is an important
example of a situation where
the point mass form of Newton's
Second Law of Motion-- f equals
ma-- is inadequate,
and one must instead
use the more general
form of the law-- f
equals dpdt-- or the
force is equal to the time
derivative of the momentum.